die gelegenheit zwei worte vorher noch
zum ablauf zu sagen wir beginnen die pk
mit zwei kurzen statements der beiden
spitzenkandidaten danach gibt es dann
die fragerunde an der fragerunde selber
sind auch kollegen von ihnen beteiligt
die per live stream dazu geschaltet sind
sie selber damit es auch im livestream
verfolgt werden kann möchten bitte ihre
fragen wenn sie dran sind direkt in die
hier im saal aufgestellten groß ohne
sprechen
unter nennung ihres mediums und ihres
namens und im anschluss an die
fragerunde wenn die pressekonferenz dann
geschlossen sein wird besteht nochmals
möglichkeit gegebenenfalls fotos dieser
beiden spitzenkandidaten zu machen ich
habe gesehen
da wurden ja vorhin schon einige gemacht
dennoch bedarf ist melden sie sich gerne
doch jetzt ohne weitere umschweife
direkt zu den beiden spitzenkandidaten
wallis weidl und tino kubala vielen dank
auch von meiner seite noch mal herzlich
willkommen
es ist ein großartiger erfolg heute den
wir beide als spitzenkandidaten in der
innerparteilichen wahl errungen haben
ist ein klarer sieg und ein wichtiges
ergebnis für uns als partei für den
gemeinsamen wahlkampf und natürlich auch
für uns als kandidaten
wir möchten uns und auch ich hier in
diesem zusammenhang ganz herzlich
bedanken für die rege teilnahme und die
breite unterstützung der mitglieder in
ganz deutschland die mitglieder haben
mit diesem ergebnis auch gezeigt dass
sie einen gemeinsamen kurs der partei
wollen das bild vor allem auch für die
mitglieder im westen die westdeutsche
mitglieder haben mich auch hier gezeigt
dass sie mittel und ostdeutschland
mitnehmen wollen
das ist ein wichtiges signal dass hier
auch spitzenkandidaten aus ost und west
diesen wahlkampf führen wollen
ich möchte mich auch bei dieser
gelegenheit bei joanna krupa und auch
bei joachim wundrak für den
innerparteilichen doch sehr fairen
wahlkampf bedanken und freue mich auch
über ihre zusage die schon vernommen
haben dass sie auch hier im wahlkampf
uns gemeinsam unterstützen wollen und
werden und gemeinsam wahlkampf zu machen
ja die afg zeichnet sich auch mit diesen
denke ich beiden kandidaten aus mit
einer promovierten volkswirt denn mit
einem handwerksmeister einer spitze in
den wahlkampf zu ziehen um auch die
breite verankert
in der gesellschaft darzustellen das
können wir mit diesen denke ich beiden
kandidaten mit uns beiden hier
darstellen darauf freue ich mich als
volkspartei machen wir politik für die
gesellschaftlichen für alle
gesellschaftlichen schichten und wollen
dabei natürlich auch alle schichten
mitnehmen das ergebnis ist auch ein
klares votum für ein ende der
innerparteilichen richtungsdebatte
deswegen ist es jetzt auch zeit die
reihen zu schließen für uns als partei
und gemeinsam nach vorne zu gehen hier
gemeinsam wahlkampf zu machen einer
erfolgreichen denke ich auch sehr
schweren wahlkampf der vor uns liegt und
deswegen freue ich mich mit alice weiter
zusammen diesen wahlkampf führen zu
können
vielen dank vielen dank auch von meiner
seite ein herzliches dankeschön an die
afg mitglieder die uns das vertrauen
gegeben haben die partei nun im jahr
2021 in die bundestagswahlen zu führen
ich bedanke mich auch für den fairen
vorwahlkampf bei joachim wundrak und
johanna kuta jetzt heißt es eben nach
dieser innerparteilichen wahl gemeinsam
und einig in den wahlkampf zu ziehen
und da freue ich mich auch auf die
unterstützung von herrn buntrock und
frau total unsere kernthemen sind
definiert durch den bundesparteitag in
dresden mit denen wir eben auch
wahlkampf machen werden und wir sind
offen für weitere fragen ja vielen dank
für das statement der beiden
spitzenkandidaten die fragerunde ist
bereits eröffnet wer möchte beginnen
der kollege von der dpa wenn sie das mal
mit dem mikrofon ausprobieren wollen
vielen dank
felix borja knapp die hälfte hat sich
beteiligt waren es 48 prozent
wie deuten sie das waren sie vielleicht
oder waren die beiden kandidaten paare
dann vielleicht auch nicht attraktiv
genug und haben auch viele dann waren
sie vielleicht doch zufrieden mit dem
ergebnis
erstmals bei einer online befragung
kommen sie auf einem bundesparteitag nie
hin
diese population eben abzudecken und
dementsprechend ist dieses votum auch
repräsentativ schlechter wäre es gewesen
wenn es in der tat nur vielleicht ein
viertel oder ein drittel gewesen wäre
aber fast die hälfte
das ist schon eine sehr hohe beteiligung
mit der wir sehr zufrieden sein können
vielleicht dadurch ganz kurz ergänzen
der durchschnittswert bei
mitgliederumfrage nicht bei 7.000 7200
oder so insofern ist es praktisch eine
verdopplung also nicht wirklich sehr
starke beteiligung
die nächste frage bitte hier jeder
kirchner deutsche welle atropa lasieren
davon gesprochen dass das ein votum für
ein ende der innerparteilichen
richtungsdebatte ist was ist denn jetzt
ihre gemeinsame neue richtung oder das
macht sie dann so sicher dass es ein
ende der debatte gibt und wählen sie
sich dass herrn wolken an ihrer seite da
ja was heißt neue richtung wir haben ja
im prinzip mit diesem mitglieder votum
gezeigt und das haben wir auch eine
vergangenheit gezeigt frau weigel als
fraktionschefin nicht als bundeschef der
partei dass wir verschiedene strömungen
in dieser partie schon abdecken und das
haben die mitglieder goutiert haben sie
auch mit ihrem abstimmungsverhalten klar
gezeigt dass wir alle strömungen in
dieser partei anerkennen und auch
mitnehmen das habe ich immer wieder auch
in meinen reden aber auch natürlich in
meinem tun indem ich durch sämtliche
landesverbände gereist bin ich mit den
mitgliedern ausgetauscht aber auch mit
allen landesvorsitzenden in unserer
partei in kontakt stehe
das ist der integrative kurs den wir
beide verkörpern und ich denke das hat
im prinzip dieses votum auch mit diesem
ergebnis gezeigt vielleicht nochmal
ergänzend dazu also wir wurden ja mit 71
prozent gewählt und das ist ein
eindeutiges mitglieder votum und dieses
votum ist lager und strömungs
übergreifend ansonsten hätte man das gar
nicht erreicht
also dieses ergebnis spricht für sich
vielen dank die nächste frage kommt von
sie haben sich spät entschieden bei
markus lanz vor wenigen wochen erst
bekannt gegeben dass wir noch mal
antreten wollen was war denn für sie die
ausschlaggebende punkte morgen um
überhaupt noch einmal als
spitzenkandidat in syrien ja dass du mit
tino copala was mich sehr überzeugt hat
also ich finde es immer probat dass man
gewisse überlegungen führt und wir
hatten ja das problem dass zwei
unterschiedliche wahlverfahren diametral
gegeneinander geführt wurden
ich hatte ja seinerzeit den antrag
gestellt im bundesvorstand das über die
spitzenkandidaten auf dem
bundesparteitag entschieden werden muss
also genauso wie bis 2017 gemacht haben
weil ich die befürchtung hatte dass wir
sonst zeitlich zu weit nach hinten
fallen denn wenn man so einen richtigen
wahlkampf hinein geht müssen die
spitzenkandidaten also die köpfe sehr
früh bestimmt werden und ich wurde eben
auch dann überstimmt durch ein
mitgliedervotum und dem habe ich mich
gefügt und die parteimitglieder die
kennt mich ziemlich genau die wussten in
dem moment wo dieser online entscheid
geschaltet wurde dass ich mich dem
unterwerfe ich werde nicht auf einem
bundesparteitag antreten gegen das votum
von 7000 mitgliedern das mache ich nicht
da kenne ich unsere partei einfach viel
zu gut
und dementsprechend hatte ich mich da
auch schon gewundert dass genau
diejenigen die eigentlich auch so eine
online abstimmung wollten sich dann für
diesen parteitag parat gemacht haben
also eine komplette paradoxe situation
und ich stehe zu meinem wort ich trete
nicht gegen einen mehrheitsentscheid an
ich trete nicht gegen das votum von 7000
mitgliedern an
und dass das genau die richtige
entscheidung eben auch für uns beide
gewesen ist dass das zeigt eben auch
dieses ergebnis viele darum die nächste
frage kommt glaube ich vom spiegel
so ist es bei den vom spiegel ich habe
eine frage haben sie beide sind das
votum ja so eindeutig war 71 prozent
diese sich da ja auch prognostisch was
herauslesen
zum einen wären sie bereit beide
vielleicht als fraktionschefs in einer
künftigen fraktion anzutreten und
darüber hinaus im herbst gibt es ja den
bundesparteitag auf dem ein neues
führungsgremium gewählt werden muss dann
wären sie doch eigentlich frau weigel
und europa ein kandidatenpaar was sich
zur wahl stellen können auf dem
bundesparteitag rang ja ich würde mal
vielleicht beginnen ja weiland ich denke
wir haben heute erst mal die kandidatur
zur spitzenkandidatur hier entschieden
bzw
die mittel habe das gewählt das steht
jetzt erst mal nicht auf der
tagesordnung sind ja schon zwei drei
schritte weiter gegangen wir wollen
jetzt erstmal geeint und auch ganz aktiv
in den wahlkampf gehen das ist unser
ziel und da brauchen wir alle mitglieder
auch alle spitzenkandidaten auch alle
landesverbände dass wir einen
erfolgreichen wahlkampf führen
die wie die nächste fraktion aussieht in
welcher größe sie dann sein wird das
hängt natürlich vom erfolg unseres
wahlkampfes arbeiten in unserem ergebnis
am ende ab und das entscheiden dann die
mitglieder der fraktion und auch wer
fraktionsvorsitzender sein will also dem
will ich jetzt auch nicht vorgreifen
das wird dann die neue fraktion
entscheiden das ist noch ein paar monate
hin
also von daher gehen wir jetzt erstmal
geschlossen in den wahlkampf vor uns
liegt in schwerer harter wahlkampf aber
noch mal vielleicht kurz gesagt ich
freue mich wirklich sehr dass die
mitglieder hier auch verstanden haben
das ist ja wichtig ist dass auch in
mitteldeutschland in ostdeutschland mit
in diesem wahlkampf integriert gehört
wir repräsentieren als ost-verbände doch
ein drittel aller wähler dieser fd wir
haben sechs millionen wähler bei der
letzten bundestagswahl gab knapp zwei
millionen kam aus den neuen ländern und
daran sieht man eigentlich dass wir uns
gegenseitig brauchen dass wir eine
partei sind eher für eine volkspartei
sind und das ist auch in den kandidaten
sich widerspiegeln muss und darüber
freue ich mich wirklich sehr dass dieses
votum auch so deutlich ausgefallen ist
und dass auch repräsentiert das hier
alle strömungen aber auch alle
regionalen gebiete in unserer partei mit
berücksichtigt wurden ja auch von meiner
seite her copala hat völlig recht das
muss man dann zu dem jeweiligen
zeitpunkt sehen
denn nicht wie entscheiden das sondern
diejenigen die uns erstens in dieser
position wollen und zweitens die uns
dann noch wählen müssen
und das ist bis dahin wenn sie unsere
partei kennen und einige von ihnen
begleiten uns ja schon über jahre her
weil sie ja auch sie wissen dass bis
dahin noch so viel wasser durch den
rhein fließt dass wir uns vielleicht
über ganz andere themen dann unterhalten
werden
das kann man da so genau noch gar nicht
sagen vielen dank
die kolleginnen haben ihn am morgen von
der taz ich wollte mal fragen weil sie
frau weile gesagt hatten
das wäre lager übergreifendes und
schwimmen zu überreichen das
stimmungsbild gewesen jetzt haben wir 50
prozent nicht abgestimmt woher wissen
sie das denn dass es so ist und auch bei
ihnen weil sich sagten die westdeutschen
sehen die ostdeutschen mitnehmen ist das
genau ausgewertet worden wer wie
gestimmt hat also können sie sich
sozusagen nachvollziehen und das auch
mit zahlen überlegen dass sie belegen
dass sie eine frage und die andere frage
es gab eine presseerklärung von herrn
wollten die war ja doch recht
ich sag mal knapp formuliert dass schon
nichts drin von wir jetzt alle
geschlossen usw
wie werten sie das denn vielen dank herr
presseerklärung gehöre ich gehe davon
aus dass der bundessprecher in
geschlossene partei möchte und natürlich
auch uns unterstützt also das ist für
mich eine selbstverständlichkeit das
muss er denke ich mal nicht aus extra
wählen wenn sie natürlich von dem
proporz sprechen wenn 50 prozent der
partei abgestimmt haben dann heißt das
ja nicht dass eine strömung gar nicht
abgestimmt also das ist ja wirklich das
wäre wirklich in der weise schon sehr
interessant das zu denken ich habe ja
natürlich auch die letzten wochen und
auch mehr monate viele gespräche geführt
habe aber auch die letzten tage viel
rückenwind auch zustimmung aus den
westlichen ländern aus landesverbänden
bekommen gerade aus niedersachsen auch
aus hessen aus rheinland pfalz bayern
baden württemberg die sehr wohl meine
kandidatur auch unterstützen mit diesem
posten ich ihn genannt hatte was auch
die strömung angeht und wenn 71% diesem
zustimmen dann kann man nicht von lagern
und strömung sprechen das ist das
gleiche ergebnis in ungefähr reform die
frau weiter zur spitzenkandidatur in
baden württemberg erhalten
ich habe in sachsen als spitzenkandidat
78 prozent erreichten habe damit im
prinzip auch die strömung abgedeckt
genau das ist doch eigentlich der erfolg
unserer partei wenn man alle mitglieder
auch alle strömungen unserer partei
mitnehmen das ist denke ich haben wir
verkörpert in unserem innerparteilichen
wahlkampf aber auch zuvor schon
ansonsten erreicht man in dieser partei
diese ergebnisse nicht und das ist für
mich eigentlich eine wertschätzung
unserer mitglieder die das genauso sehen
und darüber freue ich mich und ich denke
frau weigel und ähnlich gehen den gibt
es nichts hinzuzufügen
vielen dank ich darf mal aus dem live
streamen eine frage ein spiel und zwar
von kilian pfeffer vom hauptstadtstudio
der ard
die frage geht dann beide und die lautet
wie folgt könnten beide
spitzenkandidaten bitte noch einmal auf
die schwerpunkte im wahlkampf eingehen
die sie verfolgen wollen also es geht um
die themen die die afg jetzt im
wahlkampf spielen wird ich fange wo ich
mal an also im vordergrund wird die neue
soziale frage stehen
dahingehend dass durch die korona
maßnahmen hunderttausende von
arbeitsplätzen gefährdet sind ganze
industriezweige vor der pleite stehen
wir vor einer riesigen herausforderung
stehen und wenn mir die ängste der
bürger der arbeitnehmer der familien
aufgreifen
dann sehen wir ganz klar dass diese
existenzängste haben und wir sind
aufgerufen diese probleme diese ängste
dieser menschen zu beantworten wie
wollen wir das abfedern wie sieht
eigentlich unser wirtschaftsprogramm
unser ordnungspolitische ansatz aus und
wir haben da ja auch in der fraktion
auch politik gemacht dass der look down
völlig überzogen gewesen ist hätte
deutlich früher einer kritischen
befragung unterzogen werden müssen
auch die effektivität der maßnahmen
hätten hätte viel früher hinterfragt
werden müssen
wir haben so den wirtschaftsstandort
deutschland gefährdet und die korona
maßnahmen haben die ohnehin schon wie
sie ble strukturkrise in deutschland
noch verstärkt und beschleunigt mit der
strukturkrise meine ich den abbau von
ganzen industriezweigen der
energiewirtschaft erstens und zweitens
der automobilbranche und daneben
drittens daraus folgen die abwanderung
von humankapital also wir haben hier
natürlich einen enormen brain drain
außerhalb von deutschland brain drain
die abwanderung von talenten und von
humankapital die daraus erfolgt dass die
wirtschaftsstandorte verlagert werden
und wenn wirtschaftsstandorte verlagert
werden dann geht das humankapital mit
und einmal abgewandert kommt es auch
nicht wieder zurück also das sind
wirklich langfristige schäden auf die
wir immer und immer wieder hingewiesen
haben
und wir müssen uns die frage stellen und
auch die zukünftige zukünftige regierung
wie machen wir aus der bundesrepublik
deutschland einen attraktiven
wirtschaftsstandort wie können wir die
arbeit wieder attraktiv machen wie
können wir arbeitsplätze sicherer machen
und das ist aus unserer sicht die neue
soziale frage die wir beantworten müssen
vielen dank noch eine frage hätten
vielleicht gelingt ja also es geht
natürlich genau frau weiter hat das
wirtschaftliche schon sehr gut
ausgeführt natürlich geht es auch um die
ganzen grundrechts und
freiheitseinschränkung die wir aktuell
erleben und der diesen corona maßnahmen
die er wie sie alle wissen bislang auch
noch nicht aufgehoben wurden wir erleben
immer mehr das mittlerweile mit grund
und freiheitsrechte als gnadenrecht
umgegangen wird dass man hier überlegt
im herbst im winter eventuell kinder zu
impfen an den schulen um überhaupt die
schulpflicht beziehungsweise die
gelegenheit wieder an präsenzunterricht
in schulen teilzunehmen gewähren möchte
also das sind alles dinge die wir
natürlich genauso mit aufgreifen wollen
wirtschaft mittelstand ist ein wichtiger
punkt in vor weil hier schon angedeutet
hat auch das erlebe ich ja selbst als
handwerksmeister wie hier im prinzip
diese dieser mittelstand aber auch die
mittelschicht an sich erodiert in diesem
land erhält denn dieses land welt denn
diese wirtschaft überhaupt am laufen
wird wer bringt den volkswirtschaftlich
die steuer nein das ist der mittelstand
das sind diejenigen die im prinzip hier
diesen laden noch am laufen halten die
wenn vernachlässigt die sind in großen
teilen politisch heimatlos geworden das
erfährt man immer wieder mit gesprächen
mit unternehmern mit den bürgern und den
wollen wir als alternative auch eine
stimme geben und das tun wir auch und
ich denke da müssen wir ansetzen um auch
diesen personen wieder erfolgreich eine
stimme zu geben auch die die
bundesregierung hier zu ermahnen dass
hier die inländische wirtschaft gestärkt
wird energiekosten wurde hier
angesprochen die co2 steuer als klare
forderung dass die abgeschafft gehört
hier gibt es ja mittlerweile forderungen
der grünen die sind sogar noch zu
erhöhen was mehrkosten nicht nur für die
wirtschaft bedeutet sondern auch für die
familien für vierköpfige familien geht
es hier um wirklich hohe summen von 1500
1600 euro mehr an energiekosten wenn die
co2 steuer noch weiter steigt als es
sind alles forderungen die wir im
wahlkampf klappte stellen werden und wo
wir auch antworten geben werden vielen
dank herr gebhardt
das zdf ich wollte ein knaller zunächst
einmal fragen einen punkt im
innerparteilichen wahlkampf sehen sie
auch immer wieder gesetzt haben wir alle
mitzunehmen und sich auch gegen zum
beispiel parteiausschlussverfahren oder
dagegen stellt personen und mehr
auszuschließen ich würde gerne einmal
konkret waren an einem fall in berlin
der ehemalige landesvorsitzende
brinkmann ehemann der jetzigen
landesvorsitzenden hat ja da zum
beispiel ein dass geteilt in sozialen
medien wo der eigene die eigene
verfassungsschutz ag gesagt hat das
könnte man als mordaufruf sehen und er
trinkt phv gefordert hat weil man
ansonsten eine partei die sich dem
rechtsstaat verpflichtet sieht hat
überhaupt keine andere möglichkeit als
hierdurch ein pkv zu reagieren
also vielleicht mal in diesem konkreten
fall da heißt es da hätten sie sich
dagegen ausgesprochen im bundesvorstand
warum und wo sind für sie sozusagen rote
linie
vielen dank der bundesvorstand ist nicht
zuständig in phv andy in dieser form
einzuleiten wir haben das zurück
delegiert eine landesvorstand da wo es
hingehört und das war eigentlich auch
meine intention dazu dass sich erstmal
damit der landesvorstand beschäftigen
sollte das hat ja meiner ansicht nach
bislang getan hat sich auch da klar
positioniert auch frau brinker hat sich
dazu positioniert und von merkels diese
rechtssicherheit in diesen ganzen fragen
abzuwarten und auch formal so zu
beschreiten und das ist schon immer mein
ansatz gewesen bei allen verfahren die
wir geführt haben wie sie wissen haben
wir verfahren geführt die teilweise von
anderen justizkreisen in kassiert wurden
und diese blamage möchte ich mir einfach
ersparen und deswegen muss man sowas
prüfen und gegebenenfalls natürlich auch
abwägen in welcher position ist diese
person und welche verdienste hat auch
eine person für eine partei geleistet
auch das gilt für mich dazu ich halte
einige meinungsäußerungen in durchaus im
bereich dessen wo man die vom
grundgesetz gedeckt sind andere wiederum
nicht und das werden wir intern zu
klären
vielen dank herr schmidt
martin schmidt formal die
hauptstadtstudio mich würden zwei dinge
interessieren zum einen wenn die basis
jetzt ihrer meinung nach da gar nicht so
gespalten ist wie man das immer so
darstellt hat sich vielleicht der
bundesvorstand in seiner jetzigen
zusammensetzung schon zu sehr von der
basis gelöst weil man da doch sehr sehr
polarisierend vorgeht und vielleicht
sogar die delegierten auf parteitagen wo
es immer sehr sehr eng gewesen ist und
sehr vehement die lager gegeneinander
gekämpft haben ist die basis da
vielleicht einen schritt weiter als eben
die gewählten vertreter und eine andere
frage zu dem inhalt den sie gerade auch
vorgetragen haben jetzt vergangene woche
hat die fraktion vorgestellt
viele forderungen denen die ähnliche
richtung geben sie haben das immer
zusammengefasst auch unter dem oberthema
des great resets der anstehen würde
ausbaldowert auf dem
weltwirtschaftsforum in davos wo es
darum geht dass eine gewisse elite
wieder so dem weg ebne zu einer
sozialistischen planwirtschaft da würde
mich von frau weiter interessieren ob
sie auch diese diese gefahr dass gray
gesetz so wie er dort formuliert worden
ist sehen für deutschland also diesen
weg in den sozialistischen in diese
planwirtschaft
vielen dank vielleicht fange ich einfach
mal mit der arbeiten frage an great das
ist ja der name des buches des chefs des
weltwirtschaftsforums und da steht genau
das drin also man man nutzt sozusagen
die korona krise die sie ja zweifelsohne
ist als ausgangsposition um
einen modellwechsel herbeizuführen das
ist zumindest die zielsetzung und da
steht explizit in dem gleichen und hair
group hat eben völlig richtig gesagt wir
sehen das jetzt ja auch in europa vor
allen dingen in deutschland die
weitgehenden freiheits einschränkungen
die letztes jahr angestoßen wurden dann
die entscheidungsfindung durch gremien
die eigentlich verfassungsrechtlich gar
nicht bestimmt sind also stichwort
ministerpräsidenten runde
das sind alles solche sachen neben dem
neuen infektionsschutzgesetz dass sie
einen bundesweiten automatismus haben
also bundeseinheitliche regelungen und
dementsprechend die verwaltungsgerichte
auch ausschalten also die menschen haben
nur noch die möglichkeit dagegen zu
klagen in dem sie dann vor das
bundesverfassungsgericht ziehen
das sind alles solche stufen die ich
ganz klar als gefahr für unsere
demokratische verfasstheit sehe und in
diesem lichte ist eben auch die arbeit
der fraktion zu sehen
die genau auf diesen missstand
aufmerksam macht und was das natürlich
auch nachgeschaltet für die
freiheitsrechte bedeutet für das
wirtschaftsmodell dann für das
geldsystem beispielsweise die danach
gelagert sind also das würde jetzt so
weit führen aber das sind alles themen
die auch für sie hier sage ich jetzt mal
so als medienvertreter wirklich durchaus
interessant sind dass sie die mal bitte
unter die lupe nehmen und sich auch mal
dieses buch durchlesen was da drin steht
also das ist wirklich teilweise
haarsträubend
die erste frage war echt interessant
herr schmidt vielleicht tino möchtest du
darauf kann ich würde noch mal ganz kurz
darauf gehen direkt reset frau merkel
nennt natürlich nicht kritisieren dass
die große transformation und wenn sie
ihre reden verfolgen auch im bundestag
es kommt keine oder kaum eine rede bei
ihr aus mit transformation mit großer
transformation und da fragt man sich ja
immer was bedeutet das eigentlich
was meinen sie damit
die gibt es ja unumwunden auch zu dass
man hier im prinzip in dieser
gesellschaft auch in vielen bereichen im
wirtschaftlichen kaum ein stein auf dem
anderen lassen will man möchte alles
umdrehen möchte alles versuchen zu
verändern auch bewährtes verändern und
das ist genau das gegen das wir auch
politik machen vor wir wollen dinge die
gut laufen in diesem land erhalten das
ist auch ein stück was mit
konservatismus zu tun ich möchte die
dinge die in diesem land gut sind
behalten und erhalten die möchte ich
auch meine kinder weitergeben
so bin ich aufgewachsen so habe ich
meine eigene firma aufgebaut auf die
stolz bin wo ich heute mittlerweile doch
schweren herzens überlege ob ich meinen
kindern überhaupt empfehlen würde in
diesem land eine firma zu gründen unter
diesen voraussetzungen weil man nahezu
jeder der selbständig ist wie man hier
ackern muss wie man hier im prinzip
jeden tag von früh bis abend arbeiten
muss um überhaupt auf den grünen zweig
zu kommen das fängt an mit diesen
unsäglichen eu-regularien mit mit
bürokratie über häufung die bürger
wollen einfach in ihrem rücken auch ein
stück weit in ruhe gelassen werden und
wir erleben es hier jetzt mit diesen
kroner maßnahmen niemand sieht hier mehr
durch was hier aktuell überhaupt gilt in
welchem bundesland gilt was brauche ich
jetzt mittlerweile eine impfung um
eventuell dort und dorthin zu reisen
also sind alles dinge die schon im
anlauf sind wo ich mich manchmal frage
in supermarkt kann ich gehen erreicht
eine einfache maske andere märkte
beziehungsweise buchgeschäfte da brauche
ich mittlerweile ein test pflicht das
sind alles dinge die die leute nicht
mehr verstehen wollen und das machen wir
ganz deutlich und um nochmal über spalt
und lager zu reden das ist doch
hauptsächlich ein thema für die medien
das interessiert doch hauptsächlich sie
weil damit haben sie immer was schönes
zu schreiben die mitglieder interessiert
das überhaupt nicht so weit im gegenteil
die sagen sich und das gebe ich nehme
die auch nämlich auch als mahnung für
uns als parteiführung aber auch als
fraktionsführung auf das wir uns
gefälligst zu einem haben um hier auch
erfolgreich erfolgreich wahlkampf zu
machen das ist nämlich auch für mich
selbst mit dass diese innerparteilichen
streitigkeiten auch in der führung
auch im bundesvorstand der vergangenheit
anzugehören habe aber ich gehöre mit
frau weiter auch mit händlern aber auch
mit stefan brandner ganz klar zu dem zu
denjenigen die das immer wieder fordern
auch dinge im prinzip mit den
mitgliedern zu entscheiden und auch hier
darauf zu achten wie das in der
außenwirkung ankommt und das ist unsere
aufgabe gewesen und diesen kurs
verfolgen wir auch weiterhin
vielen dank ich habe jetzt hier im raum
noch eine frage zum spiegel noch mal ja
bitte und ja die paraguayer spiegel noch
mal laufen zwei fragen in einer die eine
betrifft ihr ziel wie wie welches ziel
setzen sie sich bei der bundestagswahl
besser zu werden als beim letzten mal
die umfragen sind ja im moment so
zwischen zehn und zwölf in dem korridor
wollen sie auch noch mal wieder stärkste
oppositionskraft wenn es dazu kommen
sollte werden wollen sie vor allen
dingen vor der fdp liegen die ja auch
ihnen auf den fersen ist und das zweite
würde mich noch mal interessieren soll
zur innerparteilichen kommunikation hat
ermorden denn ihnen heute beiden
persönlich auch gratuliert zum erfolg
oder ist das nur über presseerklärung
passiert dank vielen dank wer möchte
zuerst ja also ich hab so viele
glückwünsche bekommen ich bin noch gar
nicht dazu gekommen wirklich alle
nachrichten zu lesen
das werde ich jetzt im laufe des
nachmittages tun und vielleicht ist da
ja auch eine nachricht von jobs' leuten
und mit dem ich jetzt bisher direkten
gesprächen konnte ich weiß nicht wo du
auch die offizielle beglückwünscht und
reicht mir endlich erlöst ja also eben
das war doch eine nette pressemitteilung
und damit und zu dem ergebnis vielleicht
zu sagen natürlich wollen wir uns
verbessern das ist schon unser ziel bei
dieser bundestagswahl mit einer starken
koalition fraktion zeigt schon koalition
fraktion natürlich wieder der
bundesregierung ich bin schon in der
regierung ja mich würde es freuen wenn
mal vor der spd noch landen das wäre
denk ich mal so ein schmankerl den mann
noch mitnehmen könnte das würde mich
sehr freuen
also wir wollen selbstverständlich immer
zulegen das ist völlig klar
und das an einer konkreten zahl
festzumachen hielte ich für völlig
falsch
das zu tun natürlich ist der anreiz da
dass wir das ergebnis von 2017
verbessern
vielen dank jetzt noch mal aus dem live
stream eine frage von der jungen
freiheit lukas stein fand er fragt beide
politiker sehen sie die grün- oder er
die union als hauptgegner der schnee im
wahlkampf der möchte darauf als erste
antworten cdu obwohl die die grünen
natürlich themen besetzen die vor allen
dingen für junge menschen sehr sehr
wichtig sind
aber da muss man natürlich sich auch die
frage stellen als afd welche
überschneidungen gibt es da überhaupt
thematisch wir werden uns natürlich sehr
dezidiert und das haben wir ja schon die
letzten jahre gemacht das thema
umweltschutz anschauen
und ja wenn sie sich einfach mal das
grüne programm angucken dann das nur als
warnung dass das die reinste
mogelpackung ist also in einem plan
sozialismus herein wenn
bundesvorsitzende der grünen damit
kokettieren dass sie den
preismechanismus auswechseln wollen ja
zu was eigentlich das können sie auch
nicht beantworten dann haben sie einfach
aus dem kommunismus nichts gelernt
denn wenn sie den preis als
steuerungsinstrument ausschalten dann
haben sie nur noch den zwang
und wenn sie den zwang haben dann
wird die überleitung von einem
sozialistischen system in den
kommunismus in über geführt und das
haben wir wohl in epischer breite in der
sowjetunion gesehen und auch in anderen
kommunistischen staaten und das kann man
ja wohl nicht wollen aber unweigerlich
wenn man die logik fortführt ist es
genau das wofür die grünen auch eben
stehen die wirklich massiv international
auch gefördert werden das sind ja
riesige freude softer sind der riesige
international finanzierte wahl werben
wahlwerbespots von wahlwerbung für die
grünen
und da da staune ich wirklich dass das
alles gar nicht hinterfragt wird weil
das überhaupt gar nicht umsetzbar ist
also wir müssen mal gucken vielleicht
kommt die bundesrepublik noch mal
irgendwann zu vernunft und aber bislang
kann ich das ehrlich gesagt bei den bei
manchen leuten nicht erkennen müssen wir
einfach als partei auch mit umgehen
darum unser hauptgegner ist die cdu
vielen dank das sieht man ja auch an den
regionalen unterschieden wo die grünen
und auch die cdu stark ist die grünen
natürlich hauptsächlich in westlichen
bundesländern
im osten ist er die afg und damit sieht
man eigentlich dass die cdu von beiden
seiten zerrieben wird das eigentlich für
uns perfekt man muss es einfach so sagen
die cdu muss sich selbst mal gedanken
machen wenn sie noch konservative
politik überhaupt vertreten will mit wem
sie das eigentlich noch machen
denn fakt ist man sieht es ja an den
regierungen wo die grünen mit der cdu
regieren das dort massiv grüne politik
gemacht wird und hier zeigt sich ganz
klar die cdu wählt bekommt auch grün und
das da bieten wir eine alternative auch
in unserem wahlprogramm auch in unseren
forderungen wir wollen den positiven
wahlkampf machen auch das auch klar
definieren für was wir stehen
wir wollen nicht die dagegen partei sein
die verbots partei sind die grünen wir
wollen auch sagen um wie deutschland
aussehen soll und wird mit uns und das
wären wir auch in diesem wahlkampf
definieren und da freue ich mich sehr
drauf
vielen dank noch eine frage hier von der
dpa
nochmal schulter von der coop aller noch
eine frage sie haben sich in der
vergangenheit bereits mehrfach gegen die
russlands aktion ausgesprochen wie oder
was halten sie denn jetzt von den
sanktionen gegen belarus jetzt von den
eu-ländern losgetreten worden
man muss ja insgesamt mal schauen was
was sanktionen in dieser form überhaupt
bewirken auch dazu noch mal kurz was die
russland sanktionen angeht da zeigt sich
ja auch ein stück weit die verlogenheit
der grünen politik die diese explizit
fordern sogar noch härtere maßnahmen
gegen russland fordern und daran erkennt
man ja was eigentlich gewünscht ist man
möchte das fracking gas das dreckige
fracking gast aus den usa hier einführen
wenngleich das russische gas was durch
nord stream 2 nach deutschland kommen
wesentlich umweltschonender auch
hergestellt wird bzw produziert wird und
daran erkennt man eigentlich auch die
verlogenheit energiesicherheit spielten
wichtige eine wichtige rolle die mit
nord stream 2 gewertet wird was jetzt
die aktuellen debatten um in belarus
angeht es muss man sich mal genauer
anschauen wie die forderung dort sind
was die positionierung anderer länder
sind ich habe ein bisschen schmunzeln
trotzdem müssen es gab ja auch schon mal
einen ähnlichen fall ein flugzeug in
wien notlanden musste und auch dort im
prinzip ein passagier gesucht wurde oder
aus dem flugzeug geholt wurde
also es gab es ja schon in der
vergangenheit das ist mir eigentlich
keine sanktions forderung bekannt
also ich denke es ist sicherlich ein
schwerer eingriff in den luftraum ist
muss untersucht werden und das werden
wir jetzt erstmal ab wie die aktuellen
stände dort zu hoch sind
vielen dank da hinten noch zwei fragen
ja in sachsen anhalt plant sie jetzt als
frisch gekürte spitzenduo noch eine
unterstützende aktionen oder
veranstaltungen dort und an sie herr
grupp alle noch mal die frage sie haben
sich bislang nicht dazu erklärt warum
sie nicht mit vk zusammengehen wollten
in diese debatte die die gab es ja die
ganze zeit jetzt ist die sache gelaufen
jetzt könnten sie uns doch mal erklären
warum ja vielleicht zum ersten also
natürlich also ich bin ab nächste woche
in sachsen anhalt mehrere tage im
wahlkampf bin auch beim wahlabend da
dort mehrere termine
freue mich auch auf diesen wahlkampf
denke doch das wird eine gute nochmal
für sachsen anhalt geben wir wollen dort
stärkste partei werden in einem
bundesland das ist unser ziel und ich
hoffe dass wir das auch erreichen zu
ihrer zweiten frage was frau konnte da
habe ich mich eigentlich schon mehrfach
geäußert dazu ich kenne frau weiter
jetzt mit vier über vier jahren aus dem
fraktionsvorstand wir haben das sehr
vertrauensvoll zusammengearbeitet ebenso
im bundesvorstand
da hat einfach mein bauchgefühl aber
auch meine innere überzeugung gesagt
dass wir gut harmonieren wir verstehen
uns in vielen dingen sogar fast blind
wurden blick reicht und das ist für mich
schon der prämisse gewesen wo ich sage
dass ich mit raidl diesen
spitzenkandidaten team noch dazu jung
dynamisch hier auch darstellen möchte
wir wollen einen generationswechsel der
afg einläuten
ich denke das ist uns damit auch
gelungen vielen dank
eine letzte frage vielleicht von zdf
sie sagen das ist vor allem von den
medien auch gewollt in lager kam
sozusagen die 20 letztens in
niedersachsen auf dem parteitag nach
ihrer rede wenn er ganz deutlich hat ein
teil im standing ovations gespendet aber
es gab auch buh rufe nach ihrer rede die
als einseitig von einigen wahrgenommen
wurde pro das jetzt den landesvorstands
wie erklären sich das im kern wurde
diesem parteitag gegen diese schaltung
doch deutlich und dann vor weiter die
frage parteiinterne gegner mit diesem
werden dieses parteiinternen wahlkampfs
immer wieder auch als argument gegen sie
gesagt da könnte im sommer noch was
kommen mit der spenden geschichte das
könnte zur belastung werden in der
heißen wahlkampfphase können sie das
ausschließen oder toter vielleicht für
ihre partei kurz vor der wahl noch eine
bombe platzen die ihnen schaden nimmt
leicht direkt dazu also eins vorweg von
einer spendenaffäre allgemein zu
sprechen ist ja schon mal völlig falsch
es handelt sich hier eben auch um die
gelder die 2017
auf dem parteikonto eingegangen sind die
ein voller höhe zurückgezahlt wurden
und ich habe mir überhaupt nichts
zuschulden kommen lassen ich weiß genau
was ich getan was ich nicht getan habe
und dementsprechend kann ich das nicht
nachvollziehen dass er noch irgendwas
kommen sollen
das ganze verfahren liegt als sage ich
jetzt mal als verwaltungsakt vor einem
verwaltungsgericht und wir setzen uns
als partei gegen den bescheid der
bundestagsverwaltung ja auch zur wehr
und ich würde einfach mal vorschlagen
dass man das abwartet vielen dank herr
gebracht ganz kurz dazu ja also ich habe
in meiner rede sehr wohl dort platz zum
ausdruck gebracht wie wichtig mehr und
das hat einige wenige zu berufen
umgebracht wie wichtig mir doch eine
rechtssichere aufstellungsversammlung
die zensurliste in niedersachsen ist und
wie man die bewerkstelligt indem man die
heilt mit verschiedenen konstellationen
die man sich mal zusammen setzt auch im
überprüft wie man das hinbekommt oder ob
man eventuell eine neue aufstellung
macht das habe ich den mitgliedern mit
auf den weg gegeben das war für mich
ausdruck meiner rede die im übrigen zwei
drittel auch dies alles sehr positiv
aufgenommen haben auch diejenigen denen
meiner weise er auch eine andere
strömung angehören also ich habe dort
sehr wohl zum ausdruck gebracht wie
wichtig uns als partei und gesamtpartei
auch niedersachsen ist wir brauchen
niedersachsen auch als mit einer
rechtssicheren liste das habe ich dort
zum ausdruck gebracht und das war im
prinzip meine intention dieser rede
und ich habe dort kritik an alle
strömung in niedersachsen gegeben ganz
klar und ich hoffe und wünsche mir auch
dass ich dort jetzt geßner und auch herr
montag natürlich dort einigen wie man
dort in niedersachsen diese liste
einreicht und dass wir dort in
niedersachsen auch eine befriedung im
wahlkampf hinbekommt ganz klar
vielen dank ich habe jetzt hier noch auf
system live stream noch mal ne frage und
zwar von kilian pfeffer erneut das ist
eine zum wahlkampf und zwar fragt er
welche rolle wird die forderung nach dem
deck set also dem austritt deutschlands
aus der eu in ihrem wahlkampf spielen
das an beide gerichtet der möchte zuerst
fast dazu sagen
also wie als
zum kandidaten tragen natürlich das
beschlossene bundeswahl programm voll
mit das ist ja nun aufgenommen und wurde
auch so in dresden abgestimmt und die
forderung nach einem dexxit auch wenn es
vielleicht zunächst klingt das ist eine
eine strittige position ist lässt sich
aber so erklären dass die forderung
nachvollziehbar wird wenn man sich die
demokratie defizite innerhalb der
europäischen union eben auch ansieht und
das wird bei dieser debatte immer
ausgeblendet wir haben das auf unserem
bundesparteitag beleuchtet und
diskutiert und ich finde das auch gut
und zwar die mannigfaltigen
demokratiedefizite beispielsweise in der
horizontalen gewaltenteilung dass sie in
der kommission eine exekutive haben
nicht gewählt die auch gleichzeitig
legislative initiativrecht hat was
normalerweise nur parlamente haben also
hier haben sie zwei gewalten innerhalb
von einer nicht gewählten institutionen
da ist ja schon der erste fehler und
dann natürlich auch die störung in der
vertikalen gewaltenteilung
das nämlich supranationales recht als
europäisches recht eben nationales recht
bricht also alle verordnungen alle
gesetze die aus brüssel kommen brechen
nationale gesetze und dementsprechend
wird da auch die souveränität der
staaten ausgehebelt siehe das
königsrecht das königsrecht ist das
haushaltsrecht einer jeden nation die ja
allein durch die diversen
rettungsschirme umverteilung corona
fonds rauf und runter auch permanent
über jahre hinweg auch ausgehebelt wird
auch ein klarer verstoß gegen die
europäischen verträge
und da im lichte dieser defizite und
wird natürlich so eine forderung ein
austritt deutschlands aus der eu
nachvollziehbar aber auch immer im blick
behalten dass
wir unsere nachbarstaaten nicht
irritieren dürfen durch etwaige
sonderweg das ist auch unsere aufgabe
als partei dafür zu sorgen dass dieser
eindruck gar nicht erst entstehen kann
und das wie immer für diese lösung
europäische partner brauchen genauso wie
es cameron vor dem exit eben auch
gesucht hat beispielsweise mit seinen
zähnen reformvorschlägen bevor
eigentlich großbritannien in erwägung
gezogen hat aus der eu auszutreten
das sollte ein warnendes beispiel sein
vielen dank herr kopper da noch ganz
kurz ergänzender ist der ich denke was
für auch insgesamt sehen und was man
wirklich auch hinterfragen muss das ist
auch das was ich bislang auch vermisse
an dieser eu ist bislang dass man sich
ja mit dem austritt großbritanniens
wahrscheinlich immer noch keine gedanken
gemacht hat warum es eigentlich
geschehen ist warum ist in
großbritannien aus dieser eu ausgetreten
und ich denke da sind die reform
maßnahmen im bislang immer noch nicht
eingeleitet worden diese diese eu ist
ein stückweit nicht mehr reformierbar
und das beweist sie von tag zu tag
das haben wir gesehen mit der migrations
krise mit dem euro zuvor mit dem
finanztransaktionen die geleistet wurden
dass wir mittlerweile dort nettozahler
sind in einer größenordnung die auch
unsere volkswirtschaft kaum noch über
steht dass wir den ausgleich von den
zahlungen großbritanniens zusätzlich 13
milliarden euro pro jahr mit übernehmen
als deutschland also daran erkennt man
eigentlich dass sie wenn hier nicht
endlich reformen in dieser eu
stattfinden dass diese eu gescheitert
ist das muss man einfach mal anerkennen
ein totes pferd kann man nicht ewig
reiten und deswegen sollte man
schleunigst absteigen und ich hoffe dass
das irgendwann auch in diesen in dieser
eu in brüssel
mal ankommt wenn man auch zu
gewinnzuwachs sieht an personal der
geleistet wird auch dieses riesige
parlament was niemand versteht es
erkennt man im übrigen ja auch an den
wahlbeteiligung bei eu-wahlen diese eu
wird überhaupt nicht mehr akzeptiert
auch bei der bevölkerung nicht mehr
akzeptiert man weiß und teil überhaupt
nicht was dort überhaupt entschieden
wird
und natürlich wird auch die
entscheidungsgewalt den nationalstaaten
abgenommen auch mit hinblick zum
beispiel auf den deutschen bundestag wo
man mittlerweile selbst als cdu sagt ja
wir können hier bei gewissen
entscheidung nichts machen es wird alles
in europa entschieden
dort entscheidet man aber
fleißig mit also das ist eigentlich
diese transparenz die überhaupt nicht
mehr gegeben ist diese eu ist für viele
bürger nicht mehr verständlich und
deshalb muss hier dringend entweder
reformen gehen oder diese eu ist in
dieser art gescheitert man muss sich auf
eine andere wirtschaftsraum in dieser
form verständigen und mit starken
staaten auch dieses europa was wir alle
wollen dass europa wollen wir dass man
dieses europa weiter führt dass es hier
zu einer gemeinsamen wirtschaftsraum
erfolgreichen wirtschaftsraum auch kommt
sie in vielen tagen ja das war dann die
letzte frage ich bedanke mich recht
herzlich bei ihnen allen dass sie hier
erschienen sehen für ihre fragen und ja
wir sehen uns ein andermal ich bedanke
mich hier ja komm und dankeschön
dankeschön dankeschön ja damit kehrt die
oder zumindest wird es so dargestellt
die kfd wieder zurück zu den eigenen
wurzeln in der sagen wir mal eu-kritik
guten tag meine damen und herren von
meiner stelle aus dem studio wir haben
darüber jetzt noch ein bisschen
nachzudenken und zu reden